>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Elmer Eusman: Good morning.
So let's get started.
Welcome to the 75th Topics
and Preservations Series
lecture or TOPS lecture.
My name is Elmer Eusman.
I'm the chief conservator
here at the Library,
and it is my great pleasure to
make some introductory remarks
for today's presentation
given by Dana Hemmenway
and Matthew Clarke titled
Removing Residual Iron
from Platinum and Palladium Prints.
Before I do so, I would like to
welcome our more than 70 colleagues
who are tuning into
our live web feed.
And for those who cannot
join us live,
the Library is recording
today's presentation
and will make a high quality video
or on demand video stream available
for both the Library's main website
and Preservation site
in the coming months.
In the meantime, we invite you to
visit our website to keep abreast
of our upcoming lectures
and other ongoing work.
And should you wish to receive
announcements from us, visit loc.gov
and click on the orange
RSS icon to sign up.
So now that's out of the way,
we can actually focus our
attention on the talk.
Photographic material that Dana
and Matt will be talking about are
of great interest at the Library
and to others with collections
that hold platinum and
palladium photographs.
These photographs were extremely
popular just before and just
after the turn of the 20th century,
and they played an important role
in the rise of photography as
an art form as well as being one
of the predominant processes
that documented the
visual world at that time.
While these photographs are
often considered permanent
and quite stable, we know
from examining our collections
that unfortunately the
condition of platinum
and palladium photographs
can deteriorate over time.
Dana and Matt's work is a wonderful
example of the research we do
to understand the object's
condition,
determine why it may be
deteriorating, propose treatments
to improve it's condition
and evaluate the efficacy
of those proposed treatments.
The ability to preserve collections
for future generations --
that is our charge -- depends on
our knowledge of that deterioration
and how to arrest or correct it.
So as for Dana and Matthew --
Dana Hemmenway has been a
senior photograph conservator
at the Library's Conservation
Division since 2003.
She serves several special
collection divisions
and as a conservation
liaison is responsible
for preparing all photographs
selected
for in-house and outgoing loans.
She's currently researching
and treating the Library's
important collection
of copyright deposit prints,
the earliest motion pictures.
Before coming to the Library,
Dana was an Andrew Mellon Fellow
with the Metropolitan Museum of Art
and participated in the first cycle
of advanced residency program in
photograph conservation cosponsored
by the George Eastman House
and Image Permanence Institute.
Dana has a Master's degree from
the Winterthur University Delaware
program in art conservation,
specializing in the
conservation of photographs.
Dr. Matthew Clarke is Conservation
Scientist at the National Galleries
at the Smithsonian Institution.
He has been working in the field
of conservation science since 2010
when he joined the National Gallery
as a photograph material scientist
as part of a project
funded by a grant also
from the Andrew Mellon
Foundation focusing on the study
of platinum and palladium prints.
This work has involved the
application of spectroscopic,
microscopic and reverse
engineering techniques.
Before his work at
the National Gallery,
he investigated optical imaging
techniques and methods and analyses
at the National Institute
of Standards and Technology.
Matt has a Ph.D. in
analytical chemistry
from the University of Michigan.
Please join me in welcoming
Dana and Matt.
[ Applause ]
>> Dana Hemmenway: Thank you, Elmer.
The following presentation
is a collaboration
between two neighboring institutions
with common goals and interests.
It began like much recent
platinum photography research
under the auspices of the
National Gallery of Arts Platinum
and Palladium Initiative.
Matt presented preliminary results
of our research last November
at the project symposium in his
discussion of the technical history,
chemistry and degradation
and analysis
of platinum and palladium prints.
This talk will review and expand
on key elements of that discussion
and present results from
research conducted since then.
We will conclude with an assessment
of advantages and disadvantages
of chelation as a conservation
treatment.
The list of photographers
who worked in platinum
in the early 20th century is a who's
who of the pictorialist movement,
some of whom you see in
the image on the screen.
Others include Imogene Cunningham,
F. Holland Day, Frederick Evans,
Alfred Stieglitz and Paul Strand.
They all worked and
loved the medium.
As Stieglitz wrote, "The platinum
print has an indescribable charm,
suggesting atmosphere,
though the negative printed
on another medium may be entirely
devoid of this pictorial quality."
Today, the increasing number of
exhibitions and academic study
that include platinum photography
demonstrates our own esteem
of the medium.
The Platinum Palladium Initiative
has unquestionably heightened our
awareness and increased the
knowledge base of this medium.
While this project was taking shape
here at the Library of Congress,
I was considering treatment options
for a Laura Gilpin photograph.
Upon examining the print, I was
struck by the degree of darkening
on the recto, especially
when compared to the verso.
This Clarence White
print, on the other hand,
is stained on both sides, while this
photograph contains overall staining
as well as localized dark spots.
And I think you'll agree that
this Paul Outerbridge appears
to be in very good condition.
So what are the sources of
staining and deterioration?
It interferes not only with
our appreciation of the image
but can cause extreme brittleness,
making the print vulnerable
to physical damage.
The old addage, "A platinum print
is as permanent as it's support,"
was probably meant to be reassuring.
There are a number of possible
sources for poor aging.
Platinum catalyzed
paper degradation,
acid catalyzed hydrolysis of
cellulose, photo-oxidation
of cellulose and residual
processing chemistry.
This series of images illustrate
the steps in the process
of making a platinum print.
Sensitizing the paper support,
exposure to UV radiation
and image development.
The simplified chemical equation
show how light sensitive iron salts
are used to reduce platinum
to it's metallic state,
thereby creating image
material we see in the print.
Final processing includes
acid clearing
of unused sensitizer
and extensive washing.
If the remaining iron compounds
are not adequately removed
from the print, residual iron can
go on to produce color compounds
such as iron oxide and hydroxides
and induce future degradation
of the cellulose support.
This will cause yellowing
and loss of paper strength.
One can quickly imagine a
number of factors that lead
to incomplete clearing of prints.
First, proper processing
takes over an hour to finish.
There are multiple
prints in a single --
if there are multiple
prints in a single path,
they would need agitation
to be adequately exposed
to the processing chemistry.
And finally, that chemistry, if not
replenished, may become exhausted
and not fully able to
clear unused sensitizer.
Inevitably, mistakes were
made and shortcuts were taken.
And of course the condition
would be made worse
if the print has been stored in a
poor environment since creation.
Our study is based on the assumption
that residual iron causes staining
and paper degradation and removing
that iron will benefit
the print's preservation
and aesthetic appearance.
Historically, conservation
literature reveals a number
of approaches including
acidified bathing solutions
and powerful oxidative bleaching.
The use of chelators for paper
conservation applications was
discussed by Helen Burgess in 1991.
Since then, there have been an
increasing number of studies dealing
with the corrosive action of
metal complexes on cellulose
such as iron [inaudible], a
study we do a lot with here,
and copper pigments as well.
To date, there has only been one
published study by [inaudible]
in 1994 that directly
involves chelating iron stains
in aged platinum prints.
When developing strategies for the
current study, a number of factors
or questions help guide our
approach for testing chelators.
What delivery method
would be most effective?
Immersion, blotter washing,
application of [inaudible].
Could we select chelators
that are selective for iron?
Could we select chelators that would
not necessitate extremely elevated
pH levels to activate?
Would there be a collateral loss
of original material on the print?
That is, platinum, the
image material or calcium
and sizing that's in the paper?
What chelator concentrations
would be safe?
Would the reported long
bathing times be necessary?
How long would it take
to remove the chelator
and could it be completely removed?
And finally, is this procedure
practical for conservators?
Matt will now address how we
incorporated these factors
into our research questions
and strategies.
>> Matthew Clark: So, as we want to
look into this research and we want
to find out whether chelation
treatment is something
to be considered, we
first want to think
about how does residual iron
affect print's appearance
and does chelation both
improve removal of iron
and change the print appearance.
And finally, one of the main parts
of the research is we wanted to find
out what's the long term effect?
Because this is probably the
most understudied component.
Now, there's a challenge
here as either we have
to find a large number
of historic prints
in which we think we know
how they were made or we have
to make our own prints where
we can control at least most
of everything that goes into them.
And so that's what we decided to do.
And as part of the Platinum
and Palladium Initiative,
there's been a lot of research
at the National Gallery of Art
and at other institutions at making
platinum and palladium prints.
So shown here is Christopher
Manes [assumed spelling] making
up solutions for platinum
printing, and through the course
of the whole initiative, there's
been hundreds or possibly now
into the thousands little
different variables of step tablets
that we sliced and done at all
sorts of different conditions.
And so we can get this large
range of different images
and image qualities and study them.
But we first have to
start with something
to make the platinum prints on,
and choosing an appropriate
paper is a critical step,
and early platinum literature
we talk about we have
to use a high quality paper.
And so in this case either a cotton
or bast fiber paper
was typically used.
We don't want any buffered paper.
Alkaline buffered papers
can interfere
with the platinum printing process.
We don't want optical brighteners.
We don't want dyes and the
platinum process is better,
starch or alum rosin size
paper compared to gelatin.
So that's the type of
paper we're looking for.
It's not easy to find.
You -- most papers
now have brighteners.
They have different sizing agents
then would have traditionally
been used.
But so we're two different
institutions
so you can see what
we have available.
And it turns out National
Gallery of Art letterhead
from the 1980's roughly has
the properties that we want,
and no one really cared
if our team dug through
and removed it from their closets.
So that's what we've been using.
We've had different lots of
this, and it varies a bit.
But we can use this paper
as a good standard tool.
And then we have to find
out what's the print going
to look like in 50 years?
100 years?
And we don't want to
wait so we have to come
up with an accelerated aging system.
And that is always it's own
challenge, but we are looking
at using a few different techniques.
What we settled on was
we have this system
where we have a stainless steel rig
that we tie the paper samples to.
That goes into a humidity
aging oven.
We age it at 70 degrees Celsius,
75 percent relative
humidity for four weeks.
This is a condition that we found
generally minimized the paper
degregation while increasing --
being favorable for the
formation of stains.
And by appearance,
they mimic the stains
that we observed in historic prints.
Now we want to do analysis on
what happens to these prints.
And so of course we
look at these by eye,
and we can classify them that way.
By my point of view as a
scientist, we want to look
at some quantitative measurements so
we're going to use two techniques.
We're going to use x-ray
fluorescence, and that's going
to give us an idea
about the elements --
in this case, we're really
looking at the amount
of iron that's present
in the papers.
And we're looking at colorimetry,
which will give us a quantitative
value of how we perceive the print
and so finding out
whether it's brighter
or darker, yellower tone print.
So these are the main techniques
I'm going to focus on here.
Now, as Dana mentioned,
the prints are made
by applying the sensitizer
to the paper.
There are different types
of staining that can occur
in prints and in other objects.
We're going to focus on what
we call sensitizer stain.
And that's going to
occur in the region
where we have the sensitizer
was [inaudible] to.
So you can see where
that yellow ends,
that's the end of the sensitizer.
And we'll compare that region
after development and processing
to a region that never
had any sensitizer on it.
And looking -- we'll compare both
prints that are aged and unaged,
well processed and poorly processed.
And so this stain exists
even if the print was masked.
And you can see on the far right
that there's a tiny
faint line that exists.
We can enhance that
contrast a little bit.
And you can see it before
aging just barely and then
after aging it's more significant.
So this is kind of our goal because
if a photographer made a print
and it had a really bad stain,
it probably wouldn't have come
to the National Gallery
of Arts collection
and probably may not have come
into the Library of Congress.
It all depends on --
so we're looking
for what shortcuts could be made
but that it's still
going to cause staining?
So to do that, we have to do a
whole lot of tests and what was done
by both Dana and I and by
the broader platinum team was
to start taking shortcuts and find
out what's the kind of least amount
of shortcut you can do that's
still going to cause a stain?
So as a print goes from well
processed to poorly processed,
you will see more and more stain
form particularly after aging.
But what you really can see is that
you can take a lot of shortcuts,
have a print that looks pretty
good once it comes out of
that final washing
bath, but it's going
to form a stain after
a number of years.
And the other question we want
to know is does the amount
of iron also change when
you do these shortcuts?
And yes. As you go to more
poorly processed prints,
you'll see an increase in the
amount of iron that's in the paper.
So we know iron's important.
We know it correlates
with the image staining.
So one thing I wanted to know in
particular was is iron enough alone
to cause these stains or do
you need residual platinum
or palladium salts also present?
So is it a combination effect that
you have platinum and you have iron
and then that's what's
causing the staining?
So one of the tests
that we did was to do --
make a "platinum print"
but without any platinum.
So we added the iron solution.
We sensitized the paper.
We exposed it.
We developed it, processed
it otherwise.
It was just ferric oxalate and
no platinum or palladium salts.
And we still see staining.
You can see sensitizing line.
On the top right, you'll see
a paper before and after aging
and there's kind of an
orange line at the top.
But the paper is changing color.
And if we look at the XRF
results -- and again this is --
the reason the XRF results to
look at the amount of iron that's
in the paper, we can see
an increased amount of iron
in the sensitized region compared
to the unsensitized region
for both this iron only print
and for platinum prints.
As you know, we have
residual iron in the paper.
So iron's certainly a key
element that's going on.
It's here.
We can quantify that color change.
Again, we're using the colorimetry
so just quickly I'm going to look
at the LAB colorimetry values.
The LVAD value at the top is
a measure of the brightness
so higher numbers are
brighter paper.
The A is a value of
redness greenness.
Pretty much all other
values are positive,
which means as they
go more positive,
they're more red in appearance.
Similarly, B is yellowness blueness
and we're going to
a more yellow print.
Higher positive numbers.
You can sort of ignore
that and just look
at the little bars here
that show yellow or red.
And the aged prints, they darken
and they become more yellow.
It's a simple take away here.
So if we known iron's related to the
stain formation, can we remove it,
and what does removing it
do for us in the long term?
So chelation treatments
as Dana mentioned have been
commonly used in conservation.
We know they're being used for
photographs, but there aren't
that many studies on what's
actually taking place.
So we should quickly review,
well what is a chelator?
It's a molecule that combines
multiple sites on it's target ion.
I like to think of it as kind
of a hand holding object.
So it has these multiple
sites where it can bind.
And that makes it a strong
affinity for certain irons.
Depending on the pH of the
solution and other conditions,
that can change which
ions it will bind more.
It's not specific to iron,
but it can be more specific --
some molecules can be
more specific than others.
And I'll talk about
that a little bit.
But there are different
forms of iron.
Iron three state, iron two state
and each chelator can have it's own
binding coefficient for each state
of iron, and that can
change with pH. So very,
very common chelator is EDTA, and at
low pH it will bind more iron three,
and at a higher pH, it
will bind more iron two.
Based on the conservation
literature,
we chose three chelators.
I'll skip going through
the full chemical names,
but they are EDTA, DTPA and HBED.
EDTA is -- was invented in the 30's
and has been very commonly used.
You'll see it in many
different applications
from conservation to gardening.
DTPA is very structurally similar.
It's the one on the right to EDTA.
It has a higher binding
coefficient for iron than EDTA,
but it's also less soluable.
And then HBED is structurally
a little different.
It has a very, very strong
binding coefficient for iron three,
and so it's had a lot
of interest recently
in the conservation community
because in these aged prints
we expect most of the iron
to be in the iron three state.
We'll talk a little bit more about
each of these as we come to them.
So we're looking at
these three chelators,
and based on the other literature,
we also know that the addition
of a reducing agent -- in
this case, sodium dithionite,
is often used in order to change
one form of iron to the other.
In this case, changing it from
the iron three to iron two state,
and that can aid with removal by
the -- of iron by the chelators.
And we tested two pH
conditions that would be amenable
for conservation treatment,
pH 6 and pH 8.
After our initial test, the pH
8 gave the better visual results
and so we stuck with that plus all
three chelators are more soluable
at pH 8, especially for HBED
and DTPA that was very helpful.
So we start with a custom
negative, and we do this
because we want a large area where
we can form the sensitizer stain,
and that's going to form in this
masked area or this demin area.
And we can compare it with
this large unsensitized area.
This is something that you don't
necessarily find in the prints
in our archives or artistic prints
because either the paper was
initially sensitized throughout the
entire sheet or it was
trimmed after it was made.
So that's hard to compare, but
this gives us a really good sense
of what's happening.
And then we compare these
thoroughly processed prints
to poorly processed.
And then we age them in cycles.
So we compare unaged, aged and
print that has been aged two times
and see that it used to darken.
Both the well processed print and
the poorly processed print do change
in appearance over time, but the
poorly processed print changes more.
Now, for our chelation test,
what we want to do is we want
to take the print after one
aging cycle and then treat it
and then we will reage it to
find out what happens after that.
So in the initial test that we
did, we first hydrate the prints
in water for about ten minutes.
We did a two hour chelation
treatment, and then we washed it
in the pH adjusted
water for 30 minutes
with multiple changes of the water.
And then we looked at them.
And I think this -- the lower right
it shows you chelations aren't
really exciting treatment.
And a lot of this stuff you don't
want, a treatment that's going
to run away from you, right?
So at least here we could sit
and watch it and rock trays.
So what do we find from
our initial results?
Well, the paper sizing's important.
We did compare gelatin size
paper to alum rosen size paper,
and the gelatin retained more iron.
The chelation treatments
did remove more iron
than the water treatment alone,
and that's important to note.
And as we increase the chelation
time, so if we went to four hours,
we saw an increased benefit.
There wasn't much benefit
after four hours,
but we thought we could also
exchange new chelation baths
and improve the process.
So that's something
else we plan to explore.
Adding a reducing agent did help
removal of iron for both EDTA
and DTPA, but it did not for HBED.
That shouldn't be a surprise
because HBED is really specific
for iron three so there's no real
reason to try to reduce iron three
to iron two for an HBED process.
And I'll talk a little bit more
about HBED in a few slides,
but HBED we found was very
difficult to remove from the prints
and so we plan some more experiments
on how to aid it's removal.
So we did a whole lot
of tests after this,
and I'm not going to
go into great detail.
But we looked at different
concentrations of chelators.
We looked at increasing
the chelation time as well
as exchanging multiple
baths and the absence
or addition of a reducing agent.
In this case, the sodium dithionite.
And we looked at the
concentration of sodium dithionite
from two percent to eight percent.
And then had to do
analysis on all of them.
So it takes some time too.
There's a whole lot of data
here, and I'm not going
to go through all of this.
I'll kind of show you in general
what we saw and then I'll go
through a couple specific cases.
But the amount of iron in the print
as they were more poorly
processed will show a greater --
you can see a larger amount of iron.
The chelators all reduced the
amount of iron that was present
and general, the addition of
the dithionite further aid
of the reduction of iron, and in no
place is this going to remove all
of the iron from your prints.
And that's pretty important to note.
And there's some different
form of iron that were
in the paper before it was even made
into a platinum print before
the sensitizer was added.
And we can compare this with
the colorimetry results.
As the print ages, it gets darker.
It also gets yellower.
All of the chelators
generally bumped up the --
brightened the paper a little bit.
Dithionite tended to also
further brighten the paper.
And you may notice on the far right
something's going on with HBED
where it looks a little
bit more red.
So we kept an eye on that.
So don't try to keep all
of this in your head,
but let's just look at one sample.
So let's look at EDTA.
And in this round again,
we're taking the sample
that's been aged once.
We have a whole bunch of these,
and then we do different
chelation treatments.
So in here we're generally going up
longer and longer chelation times
and exchanging baths and
adding dithionite to it.
And it's a little difficult
to see but generally as soon
as you do the chelation
treatment, the print is brighter.
After you do aging, it darkens
some but not to the extent
as if you had not done
the treatment.
The really high concentrations
of EDTA were not very
favorable for treatment.
They were too -- this was
essentially almost saturated
and so we had some
issues with those.
But we had some otherwise
improved appearance of the prints.
If we look and just focus on the
iron content for the EDTA samples,
we'll see that if you take that
dotted line to be the amount of iron
in the poorly processed
print, after chelation all
of the prints had reduction
in the amount of iron,
the addition of the
diothinite further reduced it.
But in the end again,
we're never removing all
of the iron from the paper.
We can compare this also and look
at what else is being
removed from the paper.
So calcium is being removed from
the paper, and that's not a surprise
for anyone who has worked with
chelators, and it's typical
where calcium may be introduced
during some conservation treatments.
That's not something
we explored here.
But we just note that
calcium is being removed.
And that's the case for
all three chelators.
We can compare these to
the colorimetry results.
Now, as I said, while
this treatment isn't fast,
it's also not so substantial
that you see this giant thing
where now it's this white,
bright standard of paper.
It's not something that -- we're
not aiming for that either.
We're just trying -- we're trying
to improve the appearance
from these stains.
So the prints are --
this is after aging.
So the prints are of
improved appearance compared
to if they were not
treated after aging.
In all cases, we saw
that they did brighten
and they had a reduction
in the amount of yellow.
But they didn't make the print
back to the state they would be
in if they hadn't been properly
processed to begin with.
But they did improve them.
We did a larger battery
of tests with DTPA
because from our initial
trials it was quite --
it was somewhat most promising.
As I said, DTPA is less
soluable than EDTA so it's
about ten times lower concentration.
It has about 100 times
stronger binding to iron
so ideally it still
can remove more iron.
We did a large set of tests.
They also again -- they
brightened the paper.
Some fo that changes after aging.
It does remove calcium.
It removes iron, and the addition
of sodium dithionite improved
the reduction of iron as well.
We can compare that to
the colorimetry results.
I'm going a little faster.
You start to see all these
spots, and it's hard to tell
which direction things are going.
But the diothinite seemed to
brighten a little bit more
when you had the four DTPA samples
then it did for the EDTA samples.
And really in the DTPA we found
samples had two percent dithionite
and two two hour treatments
to be most amenable.
These were again all small changes.
So this is -- just the
conditions that we found,
to look the best both visually
and by the measurements.
So I looked at the HBED, and that
little bit of change in color.
Now, one of the things the
HBED is touted for is the fact
that when it complexes with
iron, it now has color.
And that was kind of interesting
to see during the chelation
treatment the solution turns pink
because that's the iron that's come
out, and it's chelated with the HBED
and so you can see
something's happening.
That's something different.
And there was a little bit of
tinge to the prints after they came
out even after multiple washes.
But after aging, they
become very pink.
And so what's happening is -- I
suspect there's a small amount
of HBED that isn't coming out
because it's poorly soluable.
And once it's in the accelerated
oven, it's enough it can [inaudible]
with some remaining
iron in the paper
because not all the iron comes
out, and it forms this pink stain.
We explored ways to remove HBED
and going from a ten minute washing
to 22 hours using buffer
solution and really there's only
after the 22 hours you couldn't
tell that pink was there.
And that's not really practical
for most conservation treatments.
It's certainly not an
advantage of HBED to say oh,
it's really [inaudible] to remove
iron, but you have to wash it
for ten times longer
than the other processes.
So that's all well in good but you
still have to show, does this relate
to historically aged print?
So naturally aged print.
So we went through all our data,
and I think this is a great slide
of showing we just pour over
the data and look at the prints
and talk back and forth about
what we thought was best.
And we had a print here.
It shows a somewhat
orangeish appearance.
It's a little brown.
It's about the same thickness
as the papers we're using
so that was somewhat
handy as we knew the --
we can make about the same
solutions and same time.
And one of the first things
we want to do is measure it
by x-ray fluorescence to find
out is it a platinum print?
Because you can't always tell.
And that's an important
factor to consider too.
So we want to make
sure it was platinum
because we're focusing this
work on platinum prints.
It does, and it has a lot of iron.
So then we wanted to find --
divide the print into three parts.
Have a control, do a DTPA
and an EDTA measurement.
We're kind of just kicking
HBED off the list for now.
And we want to do color imagery
and XRF measurements on areas
of the print that are
of similar density.
And that's what this
little red areas are.
That's similar optical
density of the paper.
And so these three yellow circles
are where we did the measurements.
And the print conditions we found
to be most amenable were the
chelating conditions were EDTA
for total treatment time of eight
hours with three different exchanges
of the solution and then the DTPA
plus the two percent dithionate
with a pair of two hour treatments.
So we do see a reduction
of iron, and we also see
that the print is far less orange.
It's a little bit brighter.
We can look the -- again,
calcium comes out of the paper.
A significant reduction
of iron has occurred.
What we saw here is DTPA removed
more iron compared to EDTA,
and it removed a little
less calcium.
So that was favorable.
We also noticed colorimetry.
It is brighter.
We noticed there was a little
bit of difference in the tone
between the appearance so the
DTPA was a little bit cooler tone,
and the EDTA was a
little bit warmer tone.
That sort of surprised us.
We don't know what the print
looked like before it was aged
so we can't say that one
treatment is more true
to what the original
intent of the artist was.
But that was something
that we just noticed.
And then if we take
this print and reage it,
we'll see that in the center on the
lower half is what the print looks
like if it was not
treated, and it was reaged.
So it will -- the print
will continue to darken
and become a little more orange.
Both chelated portions also darken.
They are not as dark as the
print had it not been treated.
And they are less orange
compared to the original control.
Now, we didn't compare on
that print water washing.
That's something we
did want to explore
because water washing is often used
in conservation treatments of works
on paper and on photographs
for removal of iron for removal
of acidic products and for
strengthening your paper.
And so that's something we
thought well maybe we do need
to come back to it.
We know from our earlier test our
water didn't remove as much iron,
but perhaps there's some differences
between our accelerated
aging and historic prints.
So we had another print from our
study collection that we examined,
and we treated it by DTPA
and by buffered water baths.
So we can see both with
the water and the DTPA
that the print has brightened some.
It's less orange.
The DTPA you do get this much
brighter initial -- this print --
use a lot of that stain color and it
looks very sort of clean initially.
It does darken after
aging, but not to the extent
as just the water washed alone.
And so overall, we thought this
showed the chelator can remove more
iron and improve the
print appearance.
And we can look at
the amount of iron.
Certainly in this historic print,
a lot more iron was removed
for the DTPA treatments
compared to the water treatments.
And from here, Dana is going to
summarize some of the advantages
and disadvantages that we found.
>> Dana Hemmenway: Well,
with this data in mind,
I will highlight the
advantages and disadvantages
of chelation for platinum prints.
Chelation removes iron compounds
from the print as Matt has shown.
It protects the print from
future iron-induced deterioration
and staining.
This benefit may be
mitigated, of course,
if there is incomplete
removal of iron
which could cause future
weakening and discoloration.
Alkaline aqueous immersion also
removes acidic decomposition
products and reduces discoloration.
It brightens the overall print
and restores tonal range.
Disadvantages.
You need XRF to confirm
both the presence of iron
and platinum before
proceeding with the treatment.
Our study really focused
on platinum prints.
If there are other toners or other
image materials within the print,
we didn't take that
into consideration.
They have other vulnerabilities.
Let's put it that way.
If it's a platinum print, it may
have different abilities to --
or become chelated in a
way that you don't want.
It removes material from
the paper substrate,
i.e. calcium and paper sizing.
It potentially changes the
surface texture of prints.
If used, the dithionite
reducer poses additional risk
to the print during treatment.
Any brightening of the print
from the reducing capacity
of dithionite may revert
in time as we've seen.
And lengthy bathing puts the
vulnerable platinum layer
at risk especially at the edges.
And there may be unanticipated
consequences
to a chelation treatment
that may be revealed in time.
Finally, what are the different
forms of iron in the paper?
Initially, after processing, after
aging are all forms of concern.
How much calcium lost
can be tolerated?
Can it be effectively reintroduced?
Is the treatment too
aggressive for fragile prints?
And how will modified paper
like Japine behave in immersion?
We'd like to thank the
Andrew W. Mellon Foundation
for their assistance in the
Platinum and Palladium Project.
I'd like to thank the
Library of Congress
for giving me time to
work on this project.
And we would like to thank the
individuals listed on the screen.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Questions?
Yeah.
>> Did you consider a treatment
where you would intentionally
leave the chelator in?
Not in the case of HBED obviously.
That [inaudible] problems, but I
mean, just some potential problems
with papers like Japine,
where you would have problems
with the immersion.
>> Dana Hemmenway: With removing it?
No. We didn't add that aspect
to the treatment protocols,
but it certainly is something that
could be or should be considered.
You have time?
Other questions?
[ Inaudible ]
Removing the oxygen
which would be the case
in those exhibit cases
certainly would reduce oxidative
chemical deterioration.
That sort of treatment
with the cases is reserved
for particular objects
within the museum.
It's a very expensive
and costly endeavor.
It's not practical for all items.
But certainly the less
oxygen you have there,
the less oxygen related
deterioration.
[ Inaudible ]
Would you agree?
Not all, but some.
Connie, you had a question.
>> Just one comment regarding
the paper that you guys used
to test all of these variables.
It's probably the best
possible paper support available
that we could find, and with all of
the crazy stuff that they're putting
in so many different papers
especially modern platinum palladium
prints, it's a daunting
consideration to think
about what the implications
are based
on crazy [inaudible],
etc. [inaudible].
So in other words, what you
guys have done is phenomenal,
and it's only one paper.
>> Dana Hemmenway: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>> That's just a cautionary remark.
>> Dana Hemmenway: Right.
Yeah. It's a challenge
certainly for --
>> You guys deserve great
credit for looking at this
because it is eye opening.
>> Dana Hemmenway: Absolutely.
Yeah, John.
>> On that, does this process demand
that the paper be sized initially?
I know you're using it because
these were sized papers, but that --
if not, that'd be an
interesting thing to look
at because then you
would determine the role
of your [inaudible]
sizing or that protein.
>> Matthew Clarke: Well, the main
advantage if you don't have a sizing
in your paper, it -- when you
sensitize it, it's just going
to soak it up, and you won't --
it's going to be very
expensive essentially
because really you're
going to be forming
that platinum image near the top.
And so -- and it's also --
it would be almost impossible
to even coat the paper well.
It'll -- we've tried
a lot of different --
in the broader project -- a lot
of different ways of looking
into the papers and things
like unsized papers are
not favorable for that.
>> Dana Hemmenway: And it's also
not that typical historic prints.
They would have sizing.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Matthew Clarke: I think
some of it does take some time
for the chelator to kind of
permeate and bind and come
out because you can slowly just
watching it reduce the hours
that we'll see a change.
And so that's kind of
what we're basing it on.
I don't know -- some of these --
the iron compound isn't
just in solution.
It's somehow bound
within the paper fibers.
And so that is what I think it takes
the time to get in and eventually
out and then washed away.
>> Dana Hemmenway:
Any other questions?
Yes.
>> Is iron entrained in
the high density areas
of the print when it precipitates?
>> Matthew Clarke:
There's different --
there is a higher amount of
iron total in the darkest areas
of the print, whether it's
because it's been entrapped
and it's more difficult
to get out, I don't know.
But usually in the measurements,
we'll see that it's there.
I think also some of
it after it's been --
gone through this photo reduction
process during the exposure may make
it more difficult to remove.
So the paper that -- test that I
did with only the iron present,
you could tell a difference
because we also --
we put in the same step tablet.
You could tell that there was a
little bit more iron in the area
that received more light.
But that's kind of an
initial little test.
I don't know exactly
how accurate it is.
It was enough to show here, but --
and people have seen that in other
studies where you see more iron
in the densest areas of the prints.
>> Dana Hemmenway: But then the
staining will be less obvious there,
too.
Any other questions?
>> Yes. For us prefacing
platinum and palladium printers,
should we consider adding
DT to our [inaudible]?
If so, what concentration?
What might be the risks?
>> Matthew Clarke: I think
usually there are practitioners
that will use a reducing agent
between in clearing baths,
but usually that hasn't
been sodium dithionite.
Sodium dithionite is a
stronger reducing agent
so it's been more often
used on the treatment side,
but something like sodium
metabisulfite has been used
to remove iron from prints.
And that's often done in conjunction
with EDTA baths in particular.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Dana Hemmenway: Okay.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.